ce matin devant un théâtre un théâtre
transformés en centres d'accueil pour
des réfugiés qui commencent à arriver
ici ce matin pour venir chercher des
produits de première nécessité un peu de
nourriture alors ils viennent du donbass
ils viennent des régions qui sont sous
le feu russe depuis plusieurs semaines
déjà ils viennent de kharkiv ou de
donetsk et tous racontent la même
histoire ils ont fui parce que c'était
devenu trop dangereux parce qu' il
fallait partir et qu'il n'avait plus le
choix alors certains ont dû laisser
derrière eux des membres de leurs
familles des personnes âgées peu qu'ils
ne pouvaient pas partir et qu'il ne
pouvait pas se déplacer d'autres sont
restés parce qu'il ne voulait pas
abandonner leur maison en tout cas tous
sont dans le plus grand désarroi alors
ni procès la grande ville voisine du du
donbass pour beaucoup de ces réfugiés et
bien il y à une solidarité qui s'est
mise en place les autorités tentent de
faire face parce que beaucoup de
réfugiés arrivent il est aussi des
citoyens qui prêtent leur appartement
pour une période de transition parce que
beaucoup des gens qui sont ici à arriver
à denis provost continuer leur route
vers l'ouest du pays plus sûr en tout
cas ils sont ils sont nombreux à arriver
chaque jour par leurs propres moyens par
les quelques bus qui réussissent à
sortir du donbass ou encore par par tram
et ça c'est beaucoup plus rare